Diesen hawking einer der bekanntesten physiker der welt schlägt alarm er meint dass wir die welt
So schnell wie möglich verlassen müssen die ausbreitung in den weltraum sei das einzige was uns noch retten können wir müssen bald eine mondbasis
aufbauen und auf dem mars landen viel zeit bleibe nicht mehr die zeit drängt
also wieso warum weshalb jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Stephen hawking ist wirklich aller mehr zitat die erde ist in so vielen bereichen bedroht dass es für mich schwierig ist noch positiv
Zu denken ich hoffe die großen nationen werden sich zusammentun, um diese herausforderung für uns alle gemeinsam zu meistern
Das sagte er auf dem samens festival in trondheim
Klimawandel hast du ihnen einschläge epidemien künstliche intelligenz oder das bevölkerungswachstum all das worüber wir hier berichtet haben und wo wir zum teil
Panikmache vorgeworfen wurde kann die erde schon bald unbewohnbar machen er leugne nicht die wichtigkeit
des kampfes gegen den klimawandel und die erderwärmung zitat
Im gegensatz zu donald trump der gerade die schlimmste und falsche
Entscheidung zum klimawandel getroffen hat die die welt jemals gesehen hat eines der weiteren probleme sieht er in den begrenzten ressourcen
zitat wir benötigen mehr raum und der einzige ort an denen wir gehen könnten ist der weltraum es ist an der zeit andere sonnensysteme zu
erforschen ich bin davon überzeugt
dass wir die erde verlassen müssen ja und das in den nächsten 200 bis 500 jahren also von seinem szenario
Das die welt in 100 jahren unter geht da ist der inzwischen von ab wir hatten ja dauer
Berichtet aber dass es immer eine gute idee ist ein zweites standbein zu haben
Dagegen ist ja nichts einzuwenden
Deshalb hat hawking die nationen der welt jetzt aufgerufen in den nächsten 30 jahren eine basis auf dem mond zu bauen bis zum jahr
2025 also schon in sieben jahren müssten menschen zum mars fliegen zitat die
Ausbreitung im weltraum ist das einzige was uns noch retten kann
Hawking sieht die raumfahrt vor dem nächsten sprung die besiedlung ferner planeten sei keine science-fiction mehr es gibt inzwischen rund 50
Exoplaneten die bewohnbar sein können allerdings ist die frage wie wir dahin kommen können das steht mich noch
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes in den stern erst wenn wir den warp antrieb
Gebaut haben wäre eine solche reise möglich bis dahin bleibt nur die besiedlung in unserem sonnensystem
Und die scheint immer realistischer gerade wurden unmengen wasser auf dem mars gefunden die
Lebensgrundlage für die besiedlung nasa und auch die esa wollen auf den mond wo gerade offenbar eishöhlen entdeckt wurden dazu mehr
Wie es ist also eine menge in bewegung und die chancen stehen nicht schlecht dass wir zunächst auf dem mond und später
auf dem mars permanente stationen errichten schauen wir mal
Und das am besten natürlich hier bei pixum wenn er kein video zu diesem und allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich stehen
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert ansonsten
Filtert nämlich der youtube algorithmus die videos heraus hier also hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
1000 raketen zum mars da geht es um die pläne von ihnen masken spacex ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran